it's like i feel like how long did it
take you to learn snowboarding
so i always did skiing cause my my
parents uh took me
um they do like the whole like package
holidays
i [ __ ] i hated uh skiing with because
you'd ski in like groups with like we
did like bulgaria where it's like
dirt cheap to like do it and uh you'd
have to be in a group of other like
families and i didn't really enjoy it
because i was always like the rebellious
kids i wanted to do my own thing but
to like go and like follow along and and
so i i i'd say it took me like before i
got like good enough to go on any slope
skiing it's like three weeks
um and then i taught myself how to
snowboard
uh yeah because once you've gotten the
grasp of skiing it's
very easy to kind of because you you're
already used to the laughs yeah it's
still
nothing can prepare you for just how
snowboarding works because it really
goes against everything your mind
has trained you for i mean especially
the difference between like skiing and
snowboarding right because like
in skiing it's like if you're facing
down the hill then you're gonna go
and if you're not then you've stopped
it's the literal opposite with
snowboarding right
you need to be facing the side to go and
this way you stop
but you know the thing that made me want
to change really badly was that i [ __ ]
i'm sure anyone who skis will know this
that the shoes are just
[ __ ] the worst the worst you know
because because we were concrete blocks
because we were doing because we were
doing like you know i'm really really
grateful that my parents took me on
these like
they were like the cheapest skiing
holidays you could get right so we often
stayed
really really far away from the places
and you have to put your ski shoes on
yeah like you know kind of looks like
kind of look like clown shoes yeah
so you put these shoes on like 10
minutes before you'd like 10 minute walk
from the bus
so you have to walk i'm like 13 with my
skis yeah
i'm not that strong yeah yeah walking
ten minutes with my skis in these
horrible things click clock click and
then you have to wait on the bus for 20
minutes and you can walk another like
five minutes and it's just like i hated
it yeah and then i was like you know
what i hate these shoes so goddamn much
it's so painful wearing them it's so
everything about these suck they
absolutely destroy your range yeah and i
was like i don't care what it takes i'm
gonna learn to snowboard for those god
because you just get boots yeah the
first time i wore snowboarding boots i
was like i can walk normally you know
when you're at the restaurant you know
you see these people with their trays
like clocking with their like skis yeah
like their food on it and i'm like move
out the way chad snowboarder boots
runs past oh oh don't mind me just
getting that's beer i'll take that thank
you very much you know
it's like you just get so much more
freedom and so much chiller like i don't
know
you haven't got polls to carry and so
that's why i wanted to learn it i
[ __ ]
sucked first three days i just kept
falling over oh yeah yeah me my little
brother did it at the same time and my
little brother sprained his ankle
like first day yeah gave up and i was
like nah i'm determined
i'd say snowboarding the first week that
i did it i was pretty [ __ ]
i could go down a black slope by the end
but i was doing it really badly i was
just
like going like this you know oh really
slowly but i went down it
um and then i'd say like it took me like
maybe two or three more weeks before i
felt like i could i was actually doing
it good
but yeah self-taught yeah i mean it's
it's just about like
you know just getting your body used to
those weird movements that you're
going fast yeah but also it's just like
just
you just have to commit yeah some of
these like you just have to be like
i know this is not what i'm supposed to
do but i have to do this
yeah and it's scary dude like leaning
forward on a hill like
you're not built for that you're not
your brains your brain's not built to be
like
you know this thing you're going down
fast you're gonna lean forward yeah yeah
into the danger i always felt when i was
skiing when you go fast when you're
skiing i almost feel like
it it's like safer than going slower
like
yeah weirdly yeah it felt safer because
like the way that i don't know how it
worked but when
when i was going snowboarding when i
started getting speed it did not feel
like secure at all
it's wobbling and anything that hits the
board underneath you feel it
[ __ ] tell when you're going really fast
it is [ __ ] terrifying yeah
i know if you've tumble when you're
going like really fast oh my god you're
just [ __ ]
tumbling all over the place and also and
also like tumbling with just these
massive things on your feet
just never it never feels natural you
know it's it's like having two concrete
bricks just like
yeah glue it's like it's like the green
army just kind of yeah
yeah just kind of learn like just kind
of like do this and then yeah hopefully
you feel good just don't don't put your
hands out that's the yeah
part is learning when you fall naturally
you want to put your hands out but
that's how you sprain your out your
ankles
uh ankles are your wrists you can get
like the wrist guards but they don't
help that much
i mean what i got taught cause like i
got taught by like an ex-professional
like snowboarder and he said like when
you fall like you have to fall with your
fists
yeah because if you fall like this don't
do that goes bad he did that and broke
both of his
wrists at the same time so he's like
don't do that
that [ __ ] hurts i can tell you firsthand
i just put my arms like that yeah you
just [ __ ] do this then you're good
yeah just don't fall
straight forward just get good why would
i fall literally what i what i've found
from snowboarding is that it's literally
the get
good of sports right
if you're being taught by mackey yeah
just don't be a [ __ ] and just get good
i mean like like when i started getting
used to it there was nothing that could
prepare my mind
like you know i watch youtube i i when i
watch the youtube tutorials i try to
follow what they were saying
but nothing could really prepare me for
just like getting the feel
of the snowboard because it's like you
got to shut off a part of your brain
um and relearned like another skill set
yeah when you're like snowboarding and
stuff yeah and also like just where
you're
where you're putting pressure on your
like toes and your like at the exact
point can
can determine so much on how you're
steering you get so much more control
once you realize like okay if i
just have faith if i put pressure here
it'll turn where i want it to
but you kind of gotta like not panic to
learn that yeah panicking is what
[ __ ] you yeah yeah it's good though i
mean you get the chance to go
go but obviously honestly yeah i feel
like it is a very privileged sport it is
we've been talking about a lot of
privileged activities haven't we like
kayaking
and snowboarding i remember when i was
at the ski resort
and um my phone my mom said to tell her
that i was like snowboarding
and she was like oh you rich now are you
because like like the reason like to to
us
like to to me like snowboarding and
skiing has always been like the rich man
sport yeah it's always been like the
white man's voice
that's that's that's how i feel that's
how like i was raised up
like snowboarding and skiing because you
know when i go on holiday you know
i you know visit back where's the back
home and everything like i go to like a
nice cheap beach or whatever in thailand
or whatever
um snowboarding and skiing like the only
reason i've never gone before was
because there seems to be like
so many steps and so many like so much
equipment that you need
in order just to go down a slope it's
kind of like golfing yeah
i was about to say there's two types of
rich white man sports it's you either go
skiing and snowboarding or you play golf
well
i think i saw something i don't know if
this is true or not but i saw something
and it was like
it was like based on like sports or
accidents in general what sort of them
were like
white people and it was like the most
the whitest
accident you can have is is uh on a
[ __ ] jet ski
it was like it was like 100 i can't
remember where it was it was like it was
like 99.5
of accidents on jet skis for white
people and then the next one was skiing
and snowballing yeah of course
like 97 yeah there's nothing more
have you ever been on a jet ski no have
you thought about going on a jet ski
i'd like to
because i mean in thailand obviously
with the beach and everything there's
some services where you can like rent
out jet ski for like a half an hour
whatever
um i mean it's basically just a
motorbike on water it says
you jump off of it
[Music]
no i mean it's just it's just a lot of
fun i can see how people get injured on
that though
you go pretty fast and you think that
it's water so it doesn't hurt concrete
yeah exactly
exactly yeah you think that you're
falling off at full speed it doesn't
hurt but it [ __ ] hurts oh yeah
um but it's a lot of [ __ ] fun um i
mean i haven't done much on it i mean
i've only had like
like half an hour on a jet ski on a
beach in thailand once but uh that's
pretty much it i feel like that's all
i'd need i'll be like you know what now
i'm done yeah
i've i've fulfilled the white man
experiences